whole swindle will make his big return
to the ACM stage Sunday night performing
you should be here a song he wrote about
his dad's passing this is a moment that
I know my dad would would love but I
think he's he'll be watching so it's
gonna be it's gonna be a heck of a night
another person he's got rooting for him
Pete Manny I don't mean to drop his name
but he literally texted me before I left
that wish me good luck tonight so that's
a pretty dang cool dat Super Bowl
champion you know texted me good luck
tonight the new pals recently sure to do
it on stage for a benefit concert one of
the coolest things I've ever probably
get to do on stage so I'm a big fan come
together as he fan of your music yeah I
think so he invited million we were just
he was so cool to my crew my band
everybody it's just he's a good example
of how you want to be I think if you're
a superstar like him did you get to try
on the ring I did not hate that not hey
didn't I don't think he's got his yeah
so I maybe next time now another way
Venus know that you're texting buddies
yeah yeah just no big deal